now the consultation on the planned
third runway at Heathrow has been
reopened the Department for Transport
published new evidence including updated
to noise analysis and a new air quality
plan
he throws expansion poses a dilemma for
the government block the plan and it
appears to be an T business or bakit and
looked like it doesn't care about the
environment and new data suggests
Gatwick could be a better bet when I'm
joined now by Kate Hewitt Deputy
Director at the aviation environment
Federation and palm dipped under the
executive director at back Heathrow very
good evening to you both thanks for
joining me and I'll start with you if I
can pound redundant we're hearing that
Gatwick could actually be better
economically and environmentally why are
we even still talking about Heathrow
given this new data yeah why are we
talking about it it's not what the
minister has said the minister is very
clear that they're favored option is
Heathrow they've had an independent
commission the Davis Commission 83
percent of respondents said they
supported Heathrow and even with the
consultation they're having at the
moment over 80% of the respondents have
said so as well so it's Heathrow all the
way and he's actually promised a vote in
the first half of 2018 local people want
to hit the CVI wanted until you see want
it
like I said 58,000 people responding to
this consultation saying back Heathrow
get on with it and do it so stops the
government to do that
okay and I I imagine the palms you'll be
pleased the 83% of respondents said that
they supported Heathrow since the
government's indicated that 80 percent
responses to the converse to the
consultation actually came from to
organize campaign groups you know who's
come out today and he has said this
fatally undermined his own government's
the plans or on Heathrow and this
decision that they made it wasn't in
light of this new evidence you can't
just dismiss it can you no but if you
look at what the consultations about
it's been reopened because it was a snap
election and there were a couple of
loose ends one around capacity one
around air quality which had to be put
back in and the government is quite
right to open up and do those bits that
were missed out but there's also
pointing out the
for an economic and environmental
benefits with both options and it's
saying that economically the financial
bandit benefits massively are in favor I
know where that's coming from Isabel
it's a front page of The Times today
which is out of kilter with all of the
other newspapers if you look at it and
if you look at the detail of that
article it's in the body of it it says
well actually the DFT said this the
figures that they've used at the Times
are misleading because it misses out
things like the benefits regionally 37
regional airports supporting it and also
misses out crucially Freight and this is
the biggest port by value Heathrow
anywhere in the country so if you leave
those figures out you're not actually
presenting a tribute okay here I can see
it Qing to come in there yeah I think
I'm pleased that you bring up the issue
of regional airports because yet you
know buried in the massive documents at
the government's apparent published
today is data indicating that actually
are on average airports outside London
will will lose growth as a result of a
new runway in the southeast I we think
that you know we're not really we're
really not talking about you know minor
issues that are being reopened for
consultation here there's new there's
reanalysis on on noise on co2 emissions
on economic benefits right across the
piece and we think there's a very strong
case for for politicians and others
looking fresher at this issue and there
are real concerns aren't there that if
Heathrow does go ahead with this third
runway we won't be able to meet our
environmental targets Theresa made
politically has a difficult job just
convincing her own cabinet to go ahead
with this we know Boris Johnson vastly
opposed to it and if the government is
having problems coming to consensus on
this how another London is going to it's
part of the rules and quite rightly so
someone who's got the local air in his
lungs air quality and noise are part of
the criteria that have to be met and the
minister was very clear including in a
debate today that Heathrow meets those
criteria at the moment but if you
referred to The Times article earlier
there was a big discussion about how the
modelling for air quality is changing
all the time we're becoming much more
savvy about the risks to our say it is
and what you've also got to remember is
aviation is moving on we don't have a
problem talking about the auto
Automotive cars moving on getting
cleaner getting greener
it's also happening with aircraft as
well they're quieter and they're less
polluting than
used to be and that's getting even
better and that's a fair point isn't it
Kate Hewitt that we're talking about
what 2025 at the earliest before this
could come into play things will have
moved on in terms of the emissions that
we're looking at and we have to accept
that we can't continue in this kind of
paralysis we have to make a decision
well I I think that you know given the
figures we've heard today about the UK's
economic performance I wouldn't describe
that as a as a paralysis the reality is
that the country can develop and grow
and has done very successfully over the
last few decades you know with without a
third runway we're periodically told
it's essential for the British economy
that's it I would like to see no
extension at either Gatwick or any other
Airport on that basis then that you
don't value the the need for an extra
runway well we believe that the case is
yet to be made we've got it though
absolutely their economic if they would
be cannot make impacts of Gatwick
expansion just as at Heathrow but I do
want to pick up on this point about air
quality because I mean it's quite it's
fair to point at Road Transport as you
know a significant area of concern about
Heathrow expansion it's not we're not
just talking about aircraft we're
talking about roads Road Transport we're
talking about passengers were talking
about Freight to and from the airport I
mean it would just takes an enormous
leap of faith I think to look at where
we are today and that we you know
significantly in London is significantly
in breach of our quality limits we know
they see on down that Heathrow expansion
would increase the scale of that
challenge okay yeah we're running out of
time very much creating Headroom to
allow for that for more more and more
emissions from Heathrow we're doing its
credit we have to value the environments
across not just the economic absolutely
and there's a key guy in this his name
is Tony G with juniper he used to the
executive director were friends of the
earth he is one of the people that's
been involved in setting up the plan to
make this Airport more bigger but
cleaner and greener okay I have to end
it there thank you both very much indeed
for your time this evening